(upbeat music)
- [Erdin] Innovation
doesn't happen on its own.
It needs leaders to drive it.
The Innovation Leadership Bootcamp,
is not just your regular online program.
It is immersive and it is intense.
- [Ingrid] You're going
to interact with people
from all around the world.
Learn from the best experts
and receive personalized feedback
from amazing entrepreneurs.
- [Erdin] Our coaches are MIT alumni
who are entrepreneurs,
executives, or investors.
They understand what it takes
to generate an innovation
and to design a venture to support it.
- [Mariah] They're going
to be able to push you past
what you thought was possible.
- [Erdin] You will get wide
exposure to MIT faculty
for pushing the frontiers
in different fields.
- [Vimala] Like many MIT courses,
the Bootcamp is a living lab,
where we're asking you to
identify important problems,
produce your own data and
create an effective solution.
- [Mariah] The Bootcamp
is a team project-based
learning experience.
So, you will collaborate with people
from extremely diverse backgrounds.
People who push you to look
at the world differently,
and over the course of those 10 weeks,
you will build a venture
with your team members.
- [Vimala] We really embrace
real-world challenges
and real big problems.
- [Erdin] You will see ventures
targeting sustainability,
education, economic inclusion.
It's about whether you
can design a solution
that is superior and sustainable.
- [Vimala] It's not
just for entrepreneurs.
It's really for anyone who
wants to learn how to identify
and solve problems effectively.
- [Mariah] Really successful
Bootcampers are willing
to immerse themselves in
the collaborative experience
and do so with energy.
- [Vimala] Each of our cohorts has people
from anywhere from 30 to
60 different countries.
We really think about
selecting our future members
for this innovation community
that we're helping to build.
- [Ingrid] The Bootcamp
community is this place
where amazing people around the world
that really want to change things,
that want to grow, that are ambitious,
meet other people that
are doing the same things.
- [Erdin] MIT Bootcamps is not just
about meeting your potential,
it's about expanding it.
(relaxing music)